bonsoir mesdames et messieurs sur vous
montre des images du système pour
commencer c'est lé journal c'est qu'il y
a eu du nouveau en ce qui concerne
l'éventuel retour du baseball majeur en
ville le jugement et françois cormier
françois quand la première fois le
commissaire du baseball évoque
clairement une expansion il aimerait
qu'il y a trente deux équipes plutôt que
les 30 actuelle effectivement c'est la
première fois qu'il le fait est dans
l'esprit du maire denis coderre il ne
fait aucun doute que montréal se
retrouve dans le haut de la liste des
villes qui pourraient donc se retrouver
avec une nouvelle équipe de baseball
professionnel le mercredi qui a tenu un
point de presse
tout récemment en fait en fin d'après
midi pour se réjouir oui mais pour
remettre les choses en perspective en
disant c'est bien que monsieur même fred
qu'il a rencontré d'ailleurs monsieur
coderre au mois de mai à new york face
déclarations mais il reste toute sorte
d'étape à venir il ya des comités qui
doivent étudier les différentes
candidatures et également ici à montréal
il reste aussi des étapes avoir des
investisseurs connu sérieux avoir un
nouveau stade trouver le financement
public pour ce nouveau stade qui serait
au centre ville est également toutes les
dernières études qui ont été faites qui
ont été faites avec un dollar qui
étaient à parité donc il faudrait
peut-être refaire ces études là
n'empêche en attendant le maire coderre
dit on continue de plan de match il faut
continuer de montrer que montréal aime
le baseball
on peut l'écouter ce qui est important
présentement c'est de m'assurer que l'on
puisse garder le cap
on est on fait ce qu'on a fait a
présentement les peaux l'intention de
négocier sur la place publique mais je
pense qu'on envoie un message vraiment
que montréal fait partie landes et des
villes a considéré m tinfos pour faut
pas partir en peur comme j'ai dit
voilà on continue à suivre ce dossier là
mais c'est pas pour
soyons clair soit pour demain matin non
blancs revirement montre qu'au
changement de plan pour le square viger
il faut le rappeler françois savait
créer une certaine controverse parce
qu'on voulait défaire l'oeuvre de
daudelin donc mais il faut faire quelque
chose aussi peut pas le laisser comme
sur le square exactement alors
aujourd'hui le maire denis coderre a
présenté une deuxième mouture de ce
qu'il entend faire avec le square viger
donc entre le centre-ville et le vieux
montréal
c'est effectivement s qui avait soulevé
un tollé c'est qu'on démolisse est
l'oeuvre de charles daudelin
aujourd'hui ce concept on en garde d'une
plus grande partie ce qui réjouit la
famille de l'artiste qui donne sa
bénédiction
donc la nouvelle place qui sera prête
nous dit-on pour ou 2017
on écoute le maire colère on est en
train de développer le quartier de la
santé dans le fond c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire et par ces aménagements
des espaces publics mais ça va nous
permettre justement démontré à quel
point qu'on est un joyau assez
exceptionnelle puisqu'on vous rendre
justice probablement beaucoup plus en
faisant ce qu'on fait là quand les
censures comme ça donc ce qu'on nous a
présentés patrice aujourd'hui c'est un
concept qu'il faut encore faire les
plans et devis faire approuver le tout
par le ministère des transports
les propriétaires d'une partie des
terrains mais le maire denis coderre
nous a assuré qu'il fallait pas
s'inquiéter qu'il avait de bons contacts
au ministère des transports tandis que
ça allait fonctionner ce projet-là bon
très bien merci françois au revoir